[Music]
emma
yeah help me so that i can help you
dad why do i have to talk to you you
don't talk to me it is my job to help
keep you safe maybe you should help
yourself
it's like she's built this fortress
around herself so that nothing can hurt
her
them and you're okay okay
are you okay she goes
look at me look at me i know where
you're at
what did you say to her
god
hi i wanted to say sorry for wrecking
your universe you coming in to check on
emma was a very thoughtful gesture i did
hit you both with my car you did and i
am planning on suing
i find it very easy to be in your
company you know that yeah it's been a
while for me too
[Music]
why did you run away from me i'm a
complicated person i've got baggage
after the accident when i was scared he
said that you'd be there too who i have
a bunch of times
my life is a mess this is good
i've never shared this with anyone
[Music]
i'm before perfect either felt like the
universe was bringing us together but it
has happened for a reason how did your
husband
die
we've all got wolves in us
you just have to make sure you feed the
right one
this is me
this is who i am
[Music]
you